this is the world as Vincent van Gogh
saw it or at least how the makers of the
film loving Vincent imagined he did
they've created this animated feature as
a homage to the Dutch artists it's
comprised of around 65,000 frames each
painted in oil by hand
[Music]
the film had its world premiere in very
picturesque surroundings in southeastern
France loving Vincent was shown as part
of the renowned LC International
Animation film festival
when you put these paintings together
and put the letters together they almost
create like a funeral storyboard so so
that was the main reason and also he
fascinated me as an artist with his
incredible bravery and and their passion
that you know still breathes life into
what we doing the film's storyline is
based on around 800 letters that Vincent
van Gogh wrote to his brother tio it
covers the last year of the artists life
including his struggles with mental
illness and his eventual suicide then he
comes here with a girl who I reckon was
out of his league and the next thing
he's killed himself around 100 of em
Gogh paintings provided the basis for
the film's artwork big challenge was for
us to be unified as a team of painters
because they're very different people
was there as the artistic background but
also different style and all of sudden
they all had to just leave their leave
all of that behind first the scenes were
filmed using actors these images served
as templates for the painters who
recreated them frame by frame in Van
Gogh's own signature style the truth is
I'm not important
the artists worked at three different
locations most painted they works in
Gdansk Poland some 5,000 people from
around the world had applied to take
part in the project around 100 made the
grade
to make the artists work easier these
special studios were set up each one is
equipped with a monitor and a projector
when required the template can be
projected onto the screen Katarina
Archer eTCO from Ukraine specializes in
portraits Vincent van Gogh is one of her
idols I use his experience for my work
and for my life and and now I can do
something for him I think it's because
it's him very important and he changed
our think about colours about Styles
about working the landscape it's my
thank you for him every painting was
photographed and pieced together to
create a film sequence it took 12
paintings to produce just one second of
film their style had to remain as close
as possible to Van Gogh but a time they
had to get creative Van Gogh painted
various campus sizes so you know
sometimes we had to invent a little bit
to the right or to the left sometimes
for the the reasons you know there are
ver script reasons we actually had to
change the season so we had to change a
little bit the color scheme and some of
the paintings a bit but you know we
tried to show most of the paintings as
true to the original at some point in
the film as we can at the animation film
festival in on C the film seems to have
found its audience
[Music]
that's not to send me Mia just know that
everything is animated and that they're
all paintings is just I can hardly
believe it and the play of light and
shadow and that everything is painted in
impressionist style
magis is a quantitive limo pre-dawn upon
children go yo you were really caught up
in the paintings of it's in them calls
this film was very touching and poetic
you had the impression of being caught
up in the artists emotional torment
sadaq sees two loving Vincent is set at
cinema screens this fool
[Music]
you